the fantastical trinity of american
childhood
santa claus the easter bunny and the
tooth fairy
as children we're brought up to believe
in these magical gift givers
in hopes of instilling a sense of wonder
and a sense of morality in us
children generally stop believing in
these mythical figures at around the age
of seven or eight
but why do we believe in them in the
first place
where do these traditions come from and
when did they arise in our collective
consciousness
in this video we will explore these very
questions
[Music]
santa claus is a large jolly old man
with a big white beard and a red coat
he lives in the north pole has a
workshop full of elves
a pack of flying reindeer and every
christmas eve he flies all across the
world
giving presents to children he seems
like quite the character
but how did he come to be most of us
know that he's also called saint nick
so what he's a christian saint he seems
quite different from all the other
saints we know
well he is in part the modern santa
claus is an amalgamation
of four different characters from
european history and folklore
saint nicholas sinterklaas father
christmas
and the pagan god odin saint nicholas
was an actual historical person
he lived in the 4th century and was the
bishop of myra
which is in modern-day turkey not much
is actually known about the historical
saint
but there are many stories of him
performing miracles
as well as secretly giving gifts which
is where santa claus's penchant for gift
giving comes from
saint nicholas however did not give
gifts to children he mostly gave money
to the poor
and those in need the most famous story
of his generosity is the story of the
three
dowries in which saint nicholas secretly
paid the dowries of three young women
so that they could be married and not
fall to prostitution
because of saint nicholas's famed
generosity
a figure arose in the netherlands called
sinterklaus
sinterklaus is essentially based
entirely on saint nicholas
and there is little magic surrounding
him like there is with the modern santa
claus
on december 6 the feast day of saint
nicholas
sinterklaas rides through the streets on
a white horse
dressed in his clerical garb and throws
candy and cookies to the children
he is joined by zvart pete a chimney
sweep
who punishes bad children by hitting
them with his broom
zvert pete has come under fire in recent
years for
his association with blackface
traditionally the dutch public
denied that the figure was racist but in
the last few years the opinion has
shifted
there have been efforts recently to have
the people playing pete
simply be covered in soot and not
actually
painted black another pre-santa figure
comes from jolly old england
and his name is father christmas
nowadays father christmas
is essentially synonymous with santa
claus and some british people may not
even know that they are different but
traditionally
they're not the same father christmas is
the personification of christmas
he's represented as an old man wearing
green with a wreath of holly on his head
you may recognize him as the ghost of
christmas present
from charles dickens is a christmas
carol unlike
santa he's more interested in mary
making and drinking wine than actually
giving presents to children
the tradition started in the 15th
century and had a resurgence in the 17th
century as a backlash against the
english puritans who had outlawed
christmas
seeing it as catholic and pagan and
against christian values the puritans
may have actually had a point in calling
the tradition pagan
as it is now theorized that father
christmas may have been based
at least in part of the germanic god
odin
odin was the father of the gods norse
mythology
and there is evidence that he or a god
similar to him by the name of loden
was worshiped by the english
anglo-saxons before they were
christianized
he was associated with the midwinter
festival of yule
a holiday that has been absorbed into
modern day christmas
so basically santa claus is a
combination of the english
father christmas who may have been based
on odin
and the dutch sinterklaas who comes from
saint nicholas
but that only explains a few parts of
the mythology
like the gift giving the general look
and his name
what about the rest the reindeer the
elves the north pole
well those are modern or at least more
modern editions
the reindeer are first mentioned in the
famous poem
a visit from saint nicholas also known
as a night before christmas
by clement clark moore in fact many
parts of the santa claus myth were
either created by
or recorded by that poem it is also
partly responsible for the christmas
elves
in the poem santa himself is described
as an elf for how else would he fit down
the chimney
lastly the north pole the idea that
santa lives in the north pole
started from illustrations done by the
artist thomas nass
at the beginning of the last century for
the magazine harbors weekly
during this time arctic exploration was
all the rage
so nast thought it would be fun to put
santa
up there too
[Music]
on to the bunny the easter bunny is a
rabbit that comes every easter
to give colorful eggs and candy to
children the tradition was started
by german lutherans in the 16th century
originally the easter bunny was similar
to santa in the sense that it only gave
eggs and candy to good children
though the morality tale seems to have
stopped in modern times
but the question arises why a bunny
and why eggs i mean rabbits don't lay
eggs do they
well both rabbits and eggs were seen in
pagan cultures as signs of fertility and
birth and were symbols of springtime the
germanic goddess oester
also called ostara for whom easter gets
its name
had a festival in the spring as well
which over time
morphed into the christian holiday her
symbols were the rabbit and eggs
though it's important to note that not a
whole lot is known about oester
and the information we have about her
comes from later christian writers
so the connections may not be as
straightforward as they seem
rabbits and eggs also had specifically
christian symbolism as well
bunnies ironically were a symbol of
purity
it was believed because rabbits
reproduce so much
that they might actually be
hermaphroditic and
were able to reproduce asexually because
of this they were associated with the
virgin mary
who was said to have bore jesus before
having sex
eggs were used as a symbol of christ's
resurrection
the egg shell was seen as a tomb and the
chick that came out of the tomb
was like christ rising from the dead
eggs were usually dyed red to represent
the blood of christ
unlike santa claus and the easter bunny
whose origins are
relatively clear the tooth fairy is more
of a mystery
the tooth fairy is a fairy usually
depicted as female
who comes and takes the baby teeth of
children and leaves some money behind
his compensation
it is a much more recent phenomenon
starting
in the early 20th century and only
becoming widespread in the 1920s and 30s
superstitions about baby teeth and how
to dispose of them have gone back
centuries however
and exist in almost every culture in the
world common rituals
tend to fall into two camps ones where
the child
throws the teeth somewhere like in a
fire
onto the ground or into the air and ones
where the teeth are left for something
like a dog or most commonly a mouse
in much of europe it is customary to
leave the tooth
under a pillow for a mouse to come and
take it these
mouse myths predate the tooth fairy so
it's fair to say that the tooth fairy
came from this myth so why did it change
to a fairy
and where did the money exchange even
come from in the early to mid 20th
century
the motif of the good fairy had become
popular in american culture
due to movies like the wizard of oz and
disney movies like cinderella
it is plausible therefore that the tooth
fairy was simply
part of that wave of popularity as for
the gift of money
that practice perhaps goes back the
furthest in northern europe
giving money for baby teeth is a
recorded practice as far back as the
13th century
as baby teeth were seen as good luck
charms
viking warriors would often wear them to
battle
so now you know the origins of these
magical gift-giving characters
make sure to keep this video away from
the kids and thanks for watching
hello thanks a lot for watching make
sure to like and subscribe and if you
want to
leave a comment let me know what you
think bye
[Music]
you